alors monsieur al fayed bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté de répondre aux
questions de tout le monde en parle vous
êtes en compagnie de john mclain marach
et votre directeur de la sécurité mais
avant de converser avec vous d'abord un
rappel des faits
[Musique]
donc sur cette affaire un jugement a été
rendu en septembre
1999 qui a conclu à un accident de
voiture dû à l'alcoolémie du chauffeur
de la mercedes henri-paul depuis le
début vous monsieur alpha y est vous n'y
croyez pas et vous parler de complot de
meurtre organisé par la couronne
britannique aidée par les services
secrets anglais américains et français
et quel serait le mobile de ce crime ou
de ces crimes
le mobile de ce crime
c'est un racisme absolue
la famille royale et l'establishment
dans ce pays
créé le racisme partout dans le monde
et la personne qui n'acceptera jamais
mon fils qu en tant qu'egyptien
parce qu'il faut bien voir que il
s'agissait du loret s'agit du beau père
du futur roi d'angleterre et c'est ça la
raison c'est ça le mobile
et la personne qui organise et
qui organise et cela qui a payé de sa
poche c'est le prince philip
lorsqu'il était enfant il a passé
beaucoup de temps en allemagne
il y avait un mariage avec deux généraux
d'hitler dans cette famille ça suffit
comme explication et cette personne a
grandi dans un environnement nazis
par conséquent vous voyez que la mariage
ont été tes compromettants personne ne
sait vraiment pourquoi et comment cela
s'est passé mais le ciel fayette dans le
pays en angleterre la presse vous
appelle par exemple l'égyptien où le
chèque d'arabie bien que vous soyez la
14e fortune du pays vous êtes victime
d'un certain racisme mais il y avait
aussi la la lutte de diana contre la
cour d'angleterre elle avait déclaré que
charleroi d'angleterre le futur roi
d'angleterre était incapable de
gouverner et c'est vrai que sur fond de
crise monarchique en angleterre c'était
un problème d'ailleurs james hewitt qui
a été l'amant de lady di a fait état de
menaces reçues par la princesse diana et
on peut dire qu'il a il a rien à gagner
à révéler sa à lui en tous les cas il ya
exactement puis c'est vrai on l'a vu du
reste dans d'autres programmes ou dans
d'autres interviews à la télévision
c'est exactement comme ça que ça s'est
passé
personne ne pouvaient approcher rihanna
cette femme a souffert pendant toute sa
vie de femme mariée
elle a souffert auprès du prince charles
le prince charles ne lui a apporté aucun
amour aucune vie de famille lui apporter
aucune attention à la vivait une vie des
faits atroces
elle elle vivait dans un cadre trop
étriqué troupe formelle pour elle
monsieur el fayed en attendaient
impatiemment on attendait impatiemment
le livre du seul rescapé de l'accident
c'est le garde du corps trevor rhys
jones
effectivement ils avaient été rendues
amnésiques par l'accident maintenant il
a retrouvé la mémoire mais
malheureusement il se souvient plus des
dix minutes qui précèdent le drame du
pont de l'alma et se souvient même plus
de l'itinéraire en revanche vous
démontrer qu'il ment dans son livre au
sujet de la bague offerte par votre fils
dodi al fayed à la princesse diana et
ceux ci confirment notre opinion le
garde du corps très fort hills jones a
été retourné par départ des espions date
à
laquelle
j'avais l'oeil sur sept personnes
pendant quatre mois
sans moi il ne serait pas vivant
aujourd'hui il a travaillé pour moi
pendant cinq ans je lui faisais
confiance en tant que garde du corps
et il m'a quitté soudainement avec deux
autres gardes du corps donc trois gardes
du corps mon quitter du jour au
lendemain
dans le cadre de relations humaines
normales ça ne se ferait pas ignorer il
y aurait au moins une certaine gratitude
donc sans aucune raison ça s'est passé
comme ça du jour au lendemain
on a craint qu'il retrouve la mémoire
mais on sait très bien que henri paul
qui travaille pour le service ses
secrets beauté qui travaillent à
travailler pendant trois ans
a servi le mi6
parce que tout ça c'est très délicat
toutes ces informations là donc vous
voyez on peut retourner les gens c'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé il ya
monsieur al fayed vous dit le jour de
l'accident le 30 août 1997 votre fils
dodi vous a annoncé ses fiançailles avec
la princesse diana et ça aurait été
officialisée le 1er septembre de la même
année
trevor il jones lui nie complètement il
dit c'est pas vrai ça n'a été qu'une
romance d'été
c'est ce qu'on lui a dit de dire
voyez vous que mon fils
discutera de ses relations avec la
procédure avec un garde du corps
on peut évidemment faire toutes les
suppositions ou toutes les hypothèses
que l'on veut
avec ce pays écrit m
moi j'ai eu des rapports avec les médias
le daily telegraph et autres ya des
centaines d'articles
qui porterait la folie
personne ne peut connaître les faits
personne ne peut savoir ce qui s'est
passé directement c'est mon fils moi
j'ai perdu mon fils et c'était un
complot monsieur le feuillet de
maintenant on en arrive à un point très
précis
trevor rhys-jones donc le garde du corps
dit a dit dans son livre que dodi al
fayed votre fils n'avait jamais acheté
de bagues pour la princesse diana or
vous sur injonction d'un tribunal
britannique vous avez obtenu une requête
auprès du joaillier qui s'appelle
alberto repossi place vendôme et le
joaillier a produit non seulement une
facture de la bague daté du 30 août 1997
mais en plus une vidéo où l'on voit
votre fils dodi al fayed qui entrent
dans le magasin il ya
exactement il ya beaucoup de cols il ya
des mensonges
il ya des tissu de conneries les jeux
les services secrets ont fait dire des
tas de choses à tout le monde
et je voudrais que monsieur mcnamara
vous explique un petit peu les détails
parce que lui était responsable à
l'époque et vous donner les détails de
ce qui s'est passé exactement à propos
de la bague et avec alberto repossi on
écoute
monsieur jacques lamarre a
good evening ça
permettait d'expliquer que tout ce qu'a
dit raymond régions'' dans son livre a
fait l'objet de manipulation visant à
prouver qu'il n'y avait pas de
fiançailles eh bien il faut bien savoir
que très bon risque d'user
n'a pas vu rentrer n'a pas vu de 10 ou
diana rentrer dans le bijou tri la
veille de l'accident fatal la réalité
c'est qu'ils sont allés faire du lèche
vitrine
dans la vitrine du joaillier alberto
repossi ils ont vu une magnifique bague
c'était à monaco en réalité ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment là c'est que la bague
a été envoyé à paris de dial al fayed a
récupéré la bague auprès de alberto
repossi sur la place vendôme le 30 août
dans la soirée et très boris johnson
aurait accompagné
de dial fayed chez le cahier pour
récupérer la bague mais le livre est une
manipulation les faisceaux travers
distordue pour démontrer que la bague
merci mais ce que je veux dire on va on
comprend très bien monsieur mcnamara on
va passer maintenant à d'autres points
obscurs du dossier sur lesquels je vous
demanderais d'intervenir très brièvement
pour l'épauler précisé alors les autres
points obscurs du dossier il ya d'abord
la kz lors de l'accident du fils de
monsieur al fayed de dial fayed lui il
est mort sur le coup dans l'accident
mais la princesse diana était encore
vivante après le choc elle avait eu une
hémorragie interne personnes la
diagnostiquer et on a mis 100 minutes
pour l'amener à l'hôpital est-ce que
vous pensez que il ya eu de la part des
urgentistes qui s'en sont occupés soit
une faute involontaire soit une faute
volontaire mais denver
oui il ya une erreur mais délibéré
il fallait il a fallu une heure une
heure quinze pour les deux du tunnel de
l'alma jusqu'à l'hôpital c'est
impensable
c'est évident qu'il voulait se
débarrasser d'aller de 2,10
pourquoi ont-ils immédiatement dit que
henri paul était ivre au volant
il avait le professeur lacan ci
qui était donc le médecin en charge
[Musique]
le sens de henri paul n'était pas le
sens de henri paul c'était le sens de
quelqu'un d'autre parce qu'il y avait
quinze cadavres à la morgue ce soir là
et je suis certain que l'analyse
sanguine repose sur le sens de quelqu'un
d'autre oui justement monsieur le fire
n'a trouvé dans le dans le corps de
henri-paul le chauffeur de la mercedes
30% de monoxyde de carbone avec une
telle dose de monoxyde de carbone toute
façon quelqu'un peut pas marcher alors
on s'est demandé d'où venait ce monoxyde
de carbone les analyses de contre
expertises ont été refusées pendant 48
heures on se demande aujourd'hui si le
monoxyde de carbone n'était pas contenue
dans les air bags de la mercedes est ce
que vous croyez à ça
c'est très simple
notre expert au royaume uni un autre
expert à lausanne en suisse ont démontré
que ce niveau de monoxyde de carbone
n'aurait pas pu se trouver dans le sens
de henri paul notamment lorsqu'il devait
être vivre c'est vrai vous avez raison
il n'aurait pas pu marcher ni même
conduire évidemment l'explication qui a
étonné par
les médecins français toxicologue et le
professeur lacombe sait que
le monoxyde de carbone aurait pu aurait
certainement pu venir des airbags et que
henri paul lors est inhalée
mais étant donné qu'il était mort sur le
coup il n'a pas eu le temps de respirer
et mercedes-benz nous ont dit
que les airbags ne contiennent pas de
monoxyde de carbone
aucun expert pathologiste français ne
peut expliquer la présence du monoxyde
de carbone dans le sang dans ripol c'est
impossible ce n'était pas son sens et
aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas la possibilité
d'examiner de faire des analyses qui
sont toujours détenus par les français
les français refusent catégoriquement de
laisser nos experts indépendants
accéder aux échantillons pour faire des
essais indépendants merci alors autre
point obscur du dossier c'est la façon
dont on a travaillé la police française
l'enquète n'a pas été menée d'après-vous
très correctement d'abord le lieu de
l'accident n'a pas été préservé par la
police ensuite il ya une fiat uno
blanche qui a été vu par cette témoin
qui n'a pas été véritablement recherché
et on n'a jamais parlé non plus de la
moto suiveuse qui aurait fait une queue
de poisson enfants n'a jamais bien
cherché cette moto suiveuse qui aurait
fait une queue de poisson à la mercedes
conduite par henri paul alors est-ce que
sur le lounge blanche par exemple est-ce
que vous de votre côté vous avez des
informations
et une eau dont le propriétaire était un
vietnamien cette voiture a été testé par
la police française des échantillons de
la peinture de la fiat ont été mis en
correspondance avec la peinture que l'on
a retrouvée sur le mercedes cette
voiture
comprend tête à un chien à l'arrière ça
a été confirmé ça et c'était confirmé
par les témoins de l'époque il y à des
examens qui confirme que cette voiture
correspond bien à celle ayant participé
à la collision cependant on s'en est
arrêtée là la police
et les magistrats responsables de leur
enquête se sont arrêtés là alors que à
mon avis la voiture a été trouvé mais on
a arrêté là alors il ya deux points qui
militent effectivement pour la théorie
de monsieur al fayed c'est d'abord
effectivement la bague puisque cette
bague a bien été achetée c'est une bague
dis moi oui qui a bien été acheté chez
elle berthod repos si part de dial fayed
pour ses fiançailles avec la princesse
diana il ya une autre information qui
vous a été transmis ce monsieur al fayed
très récemment par votre avocat parisien
un juge français a fait une requête
auprès des ambassades américaines et
anglaises car on pense que le numéro 2
des services secrets
mi6 était présent à paris dans la nuit
du 30 août 1997 c'est juste c'est exact
c'était en effet le numéro deux du mi6
n'importe où que ferait le numéro deux
du mi6 a à paris
on se le demande
richard jackman et il y avait un autre
nom
nicholas langham tous deux étaient à
paris
pourquoi se sont ils rendus à paris
trois semaines avant la tragédie
personne ne sait ce que vous n'êtes pas
en train finalement de mener toute cette
opération
d'abord parce que senna tout à fait
naturel mais aussi parce que en tant que
propriétaire du ritz vous êtes employeur
de henri-paul le chauffeur est donc la
couronne britannique
ouh la la famille spencer la famille de
lady di peut se retourner contre vous
pour vous attaquer yaris
c'était ça la vie peuvent pas m'attaquer
accès aux preuves les preuves existent
j'espère que la cour d'appel
se rendra bien compte de la situation
sans les services secrets français les
services secrets britanniques n'auraient
jamais perpétré ce meurtre
j'espère que la cour d'appel
la justice
parce que la france est un grand pays
moi j'ai beaucoup investi j'aime la
france et j'ai un domicile en france
donc je n'accepte pas cette situation et
j'espère véritablement que la cour
d'appel rendra justice de moi et
moi je suis père
un père en deuil et je suis un individu
qui aiment la france j'emploie un grand
nombre de personnes en france et je ne
veux pas être traité en france
comme j'ai été traité dans ce pays
monsieur alpha y ait deux dernières
questions on vous reproche de faire tout
ça aussi par vengeance contre la famille
d'angleterre parce que vous êtes la 14e
fortune du pays en grande bretagne et
vous arrivez pas obtenir la nationalité
britannique death is nothing pourtant
fait c'est pas important ça pour moi
c'est simple formalité non je veux pas
me venger je n'ai pas d'esprit de
vengeance je suis un père endeuillé par
le décès de son fils tout père qui aime
son fils ferait exactement la même chose
que moi j'ai la certitude que mon fils a
été assassiné avec la princesse diana et
les services secrets français ont
participé
à ce crime et ils sont les criminels
principaux ayant contribué à aider les
services secrets britanniques et
j'espère que les français attendront
bien cela parce que cela pourrait bien
se reproduire ça peut toucher quelqu'un
d'autre qui vit en france s'il ne faut
pas accepter cela
merci beaucoup de m'avoir donné
possibilité expliqué avéré sur la
disparition de mon fils y est la
princesse diana merci merci des dunes je
m'en accorder cette interview en
exclusivité merci beaucoup monsieur
al-fayed merci monsieur mcnamara bien
entendu les affirmations de monsieur al
fayed concernant dans le passé de la
famille royale d'angleterre que la faire
elle-même ne constituent que sa propre
version des faits à ce jour même si des
interrogations subsistent aucun rapport
officiel ou expertise sérieuse mais
venus les confirmés la cour d'appel se
prononcera définitivement dans deux mois
sur les causes de l'accident les
corrections de nourrir un t2 il a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
pouce bleus